bonjour à tous dans une précédente vidéo
j'ai évoqué l'homme de cro magnon et
l'image souvent très stéréotypée que
nous en avons on pense souvent un humain
archaïque voûte et mal dégrossi avec un
énorme pour les sur orbite air et c'est
souvent ce que la littérature et le
cinéma nous propose pourtant cet homme
des cavernes comme on aime à l'appeler
n'a pas grand chose à nous envier
certains sont peut être étonné
d'apprendre que rien ne différencie
d'albert einstein ou marilyn monroe de
monsieur cro magnon d'il ya trente mille
ans mais qu'à cela ne tienne c'est bien
ce qu'on va montrer aujourd'hui dans la
minute nécessaire prom annonce avant
tout le nombre sites archéologiques et
plus précisément d'un abri sous roche
située dans la commune des eyzies de
tayac en dordogne
c'est la commune de france qui abrite
sans aucun doute le plus de sites
préhistoriques et aussi parmi les plus
importants dans cet abri cro magnon ont
été trouvés en 1868 cinq squelettes
humains à savoir un vieillard deux
hommes adultes une femme et un foetus et
qui ont été datés depuis de la période
du grave essien c'est à dire il y as
entre 28 et 22 mille ans et qui ont
permis de définir l'homme de cro magnon
mais alors qu'est ce que l'homme de cro
magnon en réalité cro magnon c'est nous
homo sapiens pas une version ancienne
pas un ancêtre lointain mais bien un
homme
anatomiquement modernes tellement
moderne qu'il n'y aurait aucun moyen de
distinguer n'importe quel individu
contemporain d'un homme de cro magnon et
d'ailleurs le rappeur booba a tout à
fait raison lorsqu'il affirme que ses
compagnons lors la cei a rien à envier
aux stars c zéro mais oui parfaitement
tous les stars égale cro magnon et ça je
sais pas s'il sait qu'il sait sapiens
sapiens en effet tous les squelettes
attribué à cro magnon ont moins de
quarante mille ans et 40 mille ans c'est
trop court pour que des modifications
morphologiques notables apparaissent
on a donc pu dire au sujet de cro magnon
dès 1920 nous sommes arrivés à un moment
à partir duquel l'évolution physique de
lui même
tu es peut être considérée comme
terminée le problème d origine humaine
perd son caractère zoologique pour
devenir purement anthropologique et
ethnographique
en fait en préhistoire à partir de cro
magnon on peut mettre de côté
l'évolution physique parce que ben voilà
ça y est ça bouge plus pour se
concentrer davantage sur les objets que
l'homme fabrique et produits
c'est-à-dire sa culture matérielle on
parle rarement de cro magnon sans
évoquer néandertal et pour cause la
découverte de cro magnon en europe
faisait suite à celle de l'homme de
néandertal seulement douze ans
auparavant en 1856 dans l'ouest de
l'allemagne et lui pour le coup était
peut-être moins photogénique
car il avait le nez et les dents pour
imminente avec le front fuyant il crâne
allongé
c'est d'ailleurs peut-être de là que
viennent des images préconçues et si ça
se trouve les images que nous avons de
cro magnon ce sont celles de néandertal
qui sont déjà des images fausses et
voire parfois carrément des gens hâtive
confond aussi très souvent cro magnon et
néandertal même de la part d'éminents
spécialistes il met au fond tout ça est
très compliqué faut être très savant pas
du tout le brave néanderthalien avait
parfaitement compris qu'ici c'était plus
tempéré qu'ailleurs qu'il devait y avoir
du gibier
c'était beau et qu'il y faisait bon
vivre il faut bien comprendre que
néandertal n'est absolument pas un
ancêtre de cro magnon
comme vous le savez peut-être ces deux
types humains ont cohabité pendant
plusieurs millénaires et se sont
peut-être même mélanger ce n'est pas
sale cro magnon et nantes a longtemps
fait évoluer à partir d'un ancêtre
commun homo erectus on est expliqué ce
qu'est l'homme de cro magnon nous oblige
à revenir sur nos origines
alors ici on va pas s'attarder sur les
descriptions micro détaillé de toutes
les lignes et tonton c'est au final pas
grand chose après six ans à l'hôpital
mais sa part à 6 australopithecus bahr
el ghazal australopithecus d'arrêt au
moins à 10 au morro d'alpha c'est son
nom est elle derrière 6 mais un
berjallien parts aux homo sapiens et
dans tous nos missions est plutôt se
concentrer sur les trois grands espaces
qui nous intéresse à savoir sapience
néandertal
erectus nous descendons des rictus cet
ancêtre commun est une espèce africaine
il ya environ 1,8 million d'années des
populations d'homo erectus sont sortis
d'afrique se sont installés en europe et
sont devenus des néandertal d'autres
évolutions locales ont eu lieu en asie
ce qui sur la carte et appelé le plus
mais elles sont moins connus et ne
seront pas détaillés dans cet épisode
en parallèle il ya ceux qui sont restés
en afrique et qui sont devenus des
cro-magnons ou sapiens une partie de ces
sapiens et par la suite
sortis d'afrique il y environ 100 à 150
mille ans les préhistoriens appelle ça
le out of africa 2 au bout du compte
sapiens a fini par remplacer nanterre
talent en europe qui a disparu il ya
environ trente mille ans cette théorie
de l'origine africaine de la lignée
humaine était encore discutée dans les
années 80 mais depuis les analyses adn
ont définitivement confirmé cette
origine il reste toutefois possible que
sapiens n'est pas remplacé les autres
peuplement issue de la première sortie
d'afrique d'homo erectus mais qu'ils se
soient plutôt hybride et avec les
évolutions le cap
en effet on peut imaginer comme le fait
vivre
coppens qu'il n'y a pas eu que deux
sorties d'afrique mais des contacts
constants entre les populations
africaines et asiatiques
néandertal selon cette théorie serait
restée isolée en europe région
difficilement accessibles pendant les
glaciations et n'aurait donc pas pu se
mélanger aux autres populations avant
nous quitter récapitulons les choses cro
magnon c'est nous nous sommes issus de
lignées africaine dont l'histoire reste
encore largement à écrire si on admet
que l'homme est originaire d'afrique de
l'est
il faut en revanche être conscient du
billet suivant les conditions
climatiques géologique en afrique de
l'est sont propices à la conservation
des restes humains et en particulier des
ossements et c'est pour l'instant là que
sont concentrées les recherches
scientifiques
je prétends pas avoir la réponse à la
question de nos origines il ya
différentes théoriques sont toujours
d'actualité et que j'ai voulu vous
présenter ici rapidement et un
rapidement s'impose parce qu'il ya des
personnes qui ont passé leur vie à
bosser sur ces questions tongs
globalement résumé il ya la théorie
soutenue par la génétique celle de la
sortie d'afrique avec aujourd'hui on
soit un peu mieux quelques contacts très
limités entre des populations et des
alternatives comme celle d'yves coppens
pour qui l'afrique de l'est ce n'est
peut-être pas le seul berceau de l'homme
moderne
la génétique n'étant pas une science
infaillible il faut prendre ces
résultats avec précaution et garder à
l'esprit que ces conclusions peuvent
être contredite par des découvertes
archéologiques au final peu importe
lesquels de ces théories vous séduira
plus puisque ça ne modifie en rien le
constat suivant il n'y a aucune
différence morphologique ou intellectuel
entre vous et l'homme
il ya quarante mille ans certains ont
même pu dire et à juste titre si on les
avait envoyés à l'école
les premiers sapiens aurait appris à
lire ou à écrire ce qui a changé en
quinze mille ans et notre culture et
notamment le progrès technique de la
hache polie et le silex taillés à
l'arbalète puis aujourd'hui aux missiles
balistiques
au fil des générations nous avons fait
progresser les techniques et toute la
question est là à partir de quand
considère temps que nos ancêtres nous
ressemble à partir du premier ordinateur
de la première ville de la première
peinture ou de la maîtrise du feu